so about that game we played the other  night what about him we so don't know  for sure that's gonna lift the curse  whatever happens now together playing  the game in the factory I think it works  Thank You restless souls the curse has  been lifted I'll call you back someone  tried to kill me last night and I think  it's the same person who kidnapped you  where were you something's happening Mac  something evil it could be anyone  it could be someone you know how do we  stop it  we need your help  once you realize when we get down to the  wire and there's no way out  it's every man for themselves  do you guys want to play charades no  games  [Music]